[Music]
all right yeah I'm gonna be talking
about dynamic dashboards with shiny
welcome everybody thanks for coming
the these slides are available at this
URL this Lana github here are github
that concept our studio slash webinars
and there's a bunch of directories in
there this is under today's for today's
date which is 2015
Oh for so here's an overview of what I'm
gonna cover so first you know what is a
data dashboard that's that's an
important piece of information to cover
I'm going to talk a little bit about
shiny we're not going to go into depth
about shiny and when it seems a little
bit of knowledge of it and then how I'm
gonna talk about using the shiny
dashboard package which is a new packet
it's under development we're gonna we're
going to release it pretty soon it's or
still polishing off some edges somewhere
fighters on it and finally going to talk
about how to deploy a dashboard that
you've created using shiny okay all
right so dashboards in general so
dashboards are have become pretty common
on the web these days and here's here's
one example but this actually is a
dashboard for our shiny apps dot IO
service and you can see it presents you
know presents the information
efficiently so that you can you can
quickly get a sense of what's happening
there's you know there's in this
application usage you can see there's hi
application usage and then nothing and
then it jumps back up again there's one
day that's when it was deployed and
updated and created and so this is you
know this it's the purpose is to give
you all this information at a glance
it's not necessarily to go deep in depth
into some statistical analysis of this
information so that's just an example of
a dashboard so as I said you know
dashboards one usually what you usually
want to convey information efficiently
using data dashboard
and provide an intuitive user interface
for users because oftentimes the users
of dashboards are not that you know
they're not statisticians and data
scientists and the creators of them
they're people they're they're business
people we don't necessarily have that
level of expertise and going along with
that is that we usually want them to
look attractive so that they look
professional and final there's also like
a spectrum of dashboards from just
presentation focused dashboards to
exploration focused one so a
presentation focused dashboard would
just be something that just displays
information that doesn't let you
interact with it
an exploration focused one is something
that lets you explore the data slice it
dice it and get some find some valuable
insights in it okay so that's that was
you know just an overview of what we
usually expect dashboards to do well how
do they work well there's there's some
basic components that that they need to
do so one is that your dashboard
whatever software is running on your
dash where it needs to fetch the data
somehow that's it seems pretty obvious
but you need to get the data and that
can be sometimes be hard work then you
process and summarize the data and we
and we all know that our is is really
good for this and concisely present the
process data often this involves
visualization their summary tables and
and optionally we can provide
exploration tools if that's the type of
dashboard that we're working on okay so
fetching the
when you're in general you're creating a
dashboard you're grabbing the data it
has to be done quickly if you you know
if if if it takes a minute for you to
grab your data from your data source
that's generally not an acceptable
weight for most users so so if you have
a small data set relatively small data
set that's usually not a problem there's
a many different ways to do this you can
grab it using from a database using the
dbi package there's many other are
packages for database interfacing with
databases as well you could schedule
some data dumps or data summaries like
nightly if that's you know if that's the
frequency that is appropriate for your
data ready into a file and then your
dashboard can read in a CSV or
summarized or summarized data set or
maybe you have like a Web API that you
can just visit a web URL and it'll
return data in JSON or XML so and
there's there's greater packages for
ground goes as well JSON light and XML
and heavily with them our chief
scientist our studio is working on a new
XML package for for working with XML
data which should make it easier and
faster so again you know if you've got a
really large data set and you need to
and it takes too long to fetch that do
you can summarize it on a scheduled
basis and then grab that summarized data
in your dashboard so for presenting data
using shiny there's all sorts of there's
different types of outputs you can put
numbers and text you can output tables
you can output graphs and these are some
of the function names that are available
in shiny for doing these things now
we'll show I'll show some examples of
this in a bit
finally well there's these components
for explorations so in shiny you know so
far I've talked about how data comes out
to you and if you want people to be able
to explore their data they need to have
you need to have inputs so the user
needs you will send information to the
dad
bored you know under client which is a
web browser to the server which is
running our and there's very these are
mostly pretty standard web inputs
there's the text input box there's a
slider that's well that's not a totally
extent less standard thing but we have
that select inputs checkboxes radio
buttons buttons data inputs all sorts of
things like that that shiny provides for
for exploring your data for getting user
input to explore the data and and we're
also working on some new interactive
components these are some our packages
there's one called
working on called DT which provides
interactive tables that you can sort and
filter interactively so they both will
display data and they from the server
and it can also accept input from the
client
there's leaflet which is used for making
the interactive maps and we're going to
see a bit of that later and you can
we're also adding features to allow
interactions with base our graphics in
ggplot2 and we'll see that as well okay
so if you're if you're new to shiny or
if you only know just a little bit about
it I'm gonna cover some basics of shiny
right now there's gonna be pretty brief
but hopefully it's sufficient to give
you an idea of what it's all about so
what is shiny so shiny is an hour
package that's that we're developing in
our studio it's a it's a platform for
creating web applications and are and it
uses a reactive programming model which
makes it it makes it really easy for
application developers to usually
existing our knowledge to create
interactive applications you don't have
to know about all sorts of complex
underlying stuff like call back see that
all of that is sort of abstracted away
so you can just you can write this like
you're writing regular our code or
almost that like that and it's free
software it's licensed under the GPL
version 3 okay here's some
for a shiny application every time the
application is there's two sides of it
there's a user interface which is this
HTML code for generating a web page and
there's the server code which is our
code for running your analyses and
generating outputs so let me let me see
if I can run this here it's fine my art
studio session a little bit okay so I'm
running this application this is this is
really basically doesn't do anything
particularly sophisticated there's a
slider that determines how many random
points are in this scatterplot here so I
can bump it up to that's 468 27 and when
I move this slider this plot updates how
do I know how do we actually implement
that
well there's as you saw the user
interface there's a slider input and
which takes in you know some value and
there's a plot output which displays the
plot on the web page and on the server
side there's a this render plot which
this is the render plot runs the code
inside of it just it runs the plot
function that's in base R and it
captures that output and sends it to
back to the client so the important
things to to see to find these
relationships are right here I've
highlighted them so n slider input is N
and when the user updates that value it
causes the input dollar N and the
server-side code to be updated and when
these values change shiney knows that
this render plot needs to be reacts
acute 'add so it does that save the
output to the dist plot and that gets
sent back to the client so so it within
you know the within the server-side code
you're almost writing regular our code
in the UI
there's shiny has a bunch of constructs
generating these these web pages these
three functions basic page slider input
and plot output those those generate
HTML and that HTML gets sent to the
client okay and then finally you know we
have the UI and the server and we put
them together in this in a shiny app
object now if you're familiar with shiny
and you're using a UI dot our file on a
server dot our file this is a way of
creating apps with just a single file
which is there's some advantages to it
it's it's you can just cut and paste the
code and it run it in the in the
terminal like I did rather than the our
console and it just works you don't have
to go and create a directory and create
all these files to make it to run your
application so it's it's it's convenient
in that respect okay so that's that's
the real basics of shiny now I'm gonna
talk a little bit about using the shiny
dashboard all right so what is shiny
dashboard so shiny wasn't our packaged
shiny dashboard is also in our package
and it's for creating dashboard styled
layouts with shiny so now that example
shiny up that we just saw I'll run it
again it's very it's very bare-bones
looking you know the slight it's just a
white background there's a slider here
and this plot it's all black and white
and there's what shiny
for those who do is create create shiny
applications that look more attractive
more dashboard like no I should I should
I should note that you know the base
shiny package can create output that is
nicer than what I just showed you that
example app but I just showed you the
very bare-bones example app but but if
you want to create something a nice a
really nice looking dashboard it can
take it can take more work so the shiny
dashboard is design make it easier now
don't really understand this it helps
know a little bit about the underlying
components under shiny so you trying to
use this bootstrap for layout if that's
a web framework for for laying out web
pages and shiny dashboard uses admin LTE
which is the theme that's built on top
of you strap so it's all using it's all
using bootstrap all right now if you
want to install it you can just
well first install dev tools if you
don't already have it installed on your
system and then you can run install
github our studio slash shiny dashboard
this is you know once it's released on
cran then you can install it from cran
using install that packages but for now
this is how to install the development
version and there's a there's
documentation at our studio github I uh
slash I need dashboard this is I think
it's fairly comprehensive although I may
be biased since I wrote it I wrote all
that documentation so
but can do okay so here is another shiny
application this is this is one using
shiny dashboard and we can sort of hide
this stuff that isn't as important for
the this particular topic the dashboards
we have here as UI is we create the UI
using instead of basic page which is
with you before we have dashboard page a
dashboard page has three components
there's a header a sidebar and a body so
if you if you run this code here you'll
end up with an app that looks like that
so there's there's a header a sidebar
and a body
so all these dashboards created with
shiny dashboard need to have those three
components now you can start with those
components hidden there's options for
doing that if you don't want the header
if you don't want the sidebar but those
are there by default I mean they need to
be in there somewhere
okay and here's a more sophisticated app
there's most of the content in a
dashboard is going to be in the body so
this one has Deford body fluid row I'll
get to explain that in a little bit and
then a box a box is the main building
block of of dashboards dashboards using
shiny dashboard so there's one box for
the plot and one box for the controls
and easily the same essentially the same
server-side code as we visit we used
before it takes an input from the slider
and then generates a graph how do they
those boxes know to be the right width
well to understand that we have to
understand the bootstrap grid a little
bit in bootstrap there's it there's a
layout using grids of rows and columns
now you add rows
it's a row first you add a row and then
each row has 12 column and then HTML
elements like these boxes can occupy any
number of the twelve columns so the box
is by default take up six spaces so you
can put two of them side-by-side and if
you have you can add you know three
columns here fluid row three columns
with four we can have differently sized
columns three six three or four and
eight if you want different lists of
different size boxes and so I just want
to mention don't forget your columns
it's if if you have a row and you don't
put a column in it then you'll end up
with text that's like or web or HTML
components that are butting up against
the edge there and that's that's usually
not what you want with the column
there's a little bit of margin there so
it doesn't it doesn't touch this edge
there okay so back to this
here so we have the body and in the body
we have to put a row in the row we put a
box with with with 8 here and then a box
with width 4 and when we do that we end
up with this first box is twice the
width of the other one okay and there's
other
boxes that are available in shiny
dashboard there's info boxes these are
these are great for just as quickly
displaying small amounts of information
they have these nice little icons there
that are you know can help people
quickly understand what they're
displaying value box is similar just a
slightly different appearance and easier
these are all documented at this shiny
dashboard documentation site okay so
that's that's a really quick overview of
putting stuff in the body in the sidebar
there's generally two types of things we
put in there maybe one is tab items and
the other one is inputs so this is a lot
of code so just bear with me the
important parts well let me just show
you what it looks like so here we have
again this dashboard page there's three
parts of the header a sidebar and the
body then the sidebar with a sidebar
menu with these menu items and each one
of these
to bait a tab in the main body so let's
actually you know what I can run this
code and just show you what this does so
again I just cut and paste and run it
okay so this is the first tab and the
second tab when I click on first tab it
shows the first tab content secretary
chive show the second tab content and
those are linked up by this tab name
parameter here so menu item tab name is
first and that links up with this tab
item with tab name there's tightening
first and it shows first tab content
there and same for the second okay and
there's also these again these little
icons here those are those are from font
awesome which is included with shiny and
you can if you look at the documentation
of this appearance page explains how to
use icons and that works in all shiny
applications not just shiny dashboard
okay and so now the final part of
creating dashboard is the header the
header can include a title and these or
message or notification or task menus so
on the right this shows what happens
when you click on them there's a
drop-down menu and you can display
information here for for users to see
now I'm not going to in the interest of
time I'm not going to go into depth with
this because this is a less commonly
used feature but it's it's it's good to
know that it's there okay so that's
that's the layout part of a dashboard
and we'll see how to use it in a bit but
I also want to cover one other really
useful thing for component for data
dashboards and that's the the leaflet
library that that we've been working on
okay so in our
mapping an R there's our has a lot of
good tools for working with map data and
the map output is is decent but it can
be hard to interact with because you
just usually just generate the static
image and then you can't click on it or
zoom zoom into it or anything like that
but maps in the browser there's a lot of
really cool tools for interacting
interacting with maps one of them is
called we fit Jas it's it's a JavaScript
library for interactive maps and this is
the website now this this map here is
just a screenshot I took from from that
website and it's it's it's it's
interactive you can pan and zoom and it
works similar weather to Google Maps
well we were packaging though we're
packaging that up in something in our
package called leaflet and to provide
which provides a nice interface to
leaflet Jass so that's available at our
studio the documentation is that our
studio github that is leaflet don't show
you some examples from that page there
so we can load the leaflet library and
then to create a leaflet map you say
leaflet and then this is a special
piping operator so leaflet pipe it to
add tiles that adds all those images on
there step the view to latitude and
longitude the particular is a latitude
and longitude and zoom level and then
add a pop-up and this is this is just
your the Department of Statistics is you
and and this map will be interactive so
we can actually run this code in our
studio when we run it there it pops up
right there in the our studio viewer so
that's one way you can you can use it
and it is it's interactive okay that's
right there
you can also use leaflet in a shiny up
and this is getting back to dashboards
so in the UI side code you'd say leaflet
output and give it a name map and then
on the server side you say output dollar
map is render leaflet and then you just
put that we flick code in there and then
and then that that map will just show up
in your shiny application ok so I want
to show you how an example of putting
this all together so I'm show you this
demo dashboard it's it's using data from
a company called pure health one of my
friends works for them and if they have
a cloud platform for supplying data
collection and managing health data
that's comes from mobile apps and
wireless devices so and they provide an
open API to for for people to be able to
grab that data so that's what I'm using
for this demonstration app application
here so this is putting all those parts
together the dashboarding and the shiny
dashboard and we flip maps and so yes
i'm have my app code here i hit run app
it visits their api and it I'm sorry
let's see and it fetches map data and
creates this dashboard here so this is
the current location of my friend Jared
who's working at which our health he he
allowed me to track him today and and we
can see where he's been so so today he's
seven kilometers he's the closest place
well closest venue that he's at is home
there's these red dots are like known
locations they're called venues and he's
four metres from home which I guess
probably means he's inside his house and
this is this is real this is real time
and we can you know this leaflet map
what's the zoom in here and zoom out now
this is sort of a more of a presentation
focused dashboard but we can also have
more exploratory tools as well so this
is using that switching tabs here click
on location history so okay this is
showing where he's been in the last
several days so hopefully you can see
these the text on this graph here so
this is from April 11th to a pro 15s is
were in Minneapolis so he's uh he's
troubled from his home to downtown
Minneapolis to down here near the
airport and with shiny you can have
these these filtering tools so when we
interact with this slider let's say I
want to I just want to see just the data
points that are within four kilometers
at home so this is where he's been what
he's been during this time that's within
four kilometers of home
and you can see that he's been often at
these other venues and on this plot on
the bottom this is generated by ggplot
and was plotted on the bottom this is uh
this is the distance from home so you
can see that in most this time he's been
close to home and then he traveled far
away that was probably that trip down
near the airport went back around home
and had a shorter distance trip and
stayed in wherever it was for a long
time and this orange dotted line that's
the cutoff point for the distance from
from home
anything above that line is not being
displayed on the map anymore but now we
could reset it and there's okay now I'm
going to show you this new feature that
we're working on in SHINee right now
which is to do this interacting with a
ggplot graph so I've this is called
brushing of the plots I've selected this
region and this also does filtering now
the graph is only does or the map is
only displaying location data that's
within this day from April 11th to April
12th that's when we stayed close to home
that day we can move it over from April
12th to a pristine was at home then we
went down near the airport here and if
we want to find out more about that we
can just let's see we could say okay I
just want to look at this region of time
what is this here
turns out during this time he was near
the Mall of America so that's kind of
interesting and then this other day he
was at home went to work all day in
downtown Minneapolis and then went back
home so with these new plot interactions
that we have it should open up some new
doors for being able to to take a deep
dive into your data and explore some
interesting connections in it
finally this dashboard I just wanted to
give one other example of a presentation
focus dashboard and this is this is one
that uses you know your existing our
knowledge so this is these are just
graphs that are made with ggplot which
if you're if you're familiar is are
you're probably familiar with ggplot2
this is calorimeter data we're measuring
oxygen intake carbon dioxide output and
activity so this this person was hooked
up to this equipment and had three
exercise sessions we can see there's a
large increase of oxygen and carbon
dioxide at those times and spikes in
activity as well and you know we can see
a correlation here between these
variables oxygen oxygen
carbon dioxide output there's almost a
perfect linear correlation something you
must never see in real world data
activity and oxygen not as close
correlation and a histogram of oxygen
use okay so that is an example of a
dashboard that's putting all these
things together I mean we have here
these are all put in boxes you know be
going back to this these are put in
boxes we have this box has colored
header we have these inputs we have a
ggplot output here and we have these
other of these info boxes too which are
again a quick way of presenting
information for people to see all right
so let's say we have this dashboard and
and we wanted to play it so so far I've
you know I've just been running it
locally on my system but usually you
want to be able to share this with other
people so and you can't just run it you
know shiny on your computer and allow
people to connect to it I mean you can
but it won't it won't restart properly
if your if your app exits for whatever
reason and you can only one run one app
at a time which is probably not ideal so
in order to deploy it there's for real
there's there's three options there's
shiny server open source
there's shiny server Pro and there's
China app Co now the first two of these
you run them on your own Linux server so
you set up your own Linux server either
you know could be in-house so you could
I guess you could install it in some
cloud service like Amazon AWS and then
you install shiny server and and you can
put your apps on there the third option
is China app step I oh this is uh I
think we came out of our beta testing
phase very recently about a month ago
and this is this is a hosting service
where you just
deploy your app to our servers and we
manage all the rest we make it really
easy to deploy it and we deal with you
know load management and and monitoring
and things like that okay so let me I'll
talk real quick about these different
options some of the pros and cons so the
open-source version of shinee server
it's free software it's licensed under
the a GPL
you have to run it on your own linux
server which can be a pro or con but
it's it's it's more work but on the
other hand you can keep it internal if
you need to there's no authentication or
SSL so it's not very secure it's not
built for security it's more for public
facing apps and there's only a one-hour
process perhaps so it's better for
relatively light traffic now I should
note that one a single hour process
running SHINee can actually handle
multiple multiple connections from users
but if you have a lot of users showing
the same hour process it can it can get
bogged down shiny server pro it's
similar to shiny server open-source oops
it's similar the shiny server
open-source you run it on your own linux
server there's authentication and SSL
and which is an advantage over
open-source version and there's multiple
our processes per app so if you get a
lot of traffic it's good for that and it
also provides a an admin and monitoring
dashboard alright finally ok shiny up Co
we manage us it's hosted by our studio
in Amazon AWS it supports SSL
authentication it close allows multiple
our processes per app there's an admin
and monitoring dashboard which which
actually showed you right at the
beginning of this at this talk one thing
it doesn't do is there's not persistent
storage so if you if you're if you want
to collect user input you'd have to send
that off that data to
some remote data store so if that's
something that you really need either
need to do that or you should assign a
shiny server or shining server Pro might
be more appropriate in that case okay so
I'm gonna talk about deploying just
shiny on Io because that's the easiest
way to do it it's the simplest way and
the other ones would be explaining how
to do that would take quite a bit more
time so first you have to install this
shiny UPS package you can use dev tools
again to do call install github our
studio slash shiny apps okay next you
have to visit the shiny up style website
and create account there and then
configure the shiny shiny apps package
there's the getting started guide at
this URL is is very straightforward
there's there is a number of steps but
it's it should be it pretty
straightforward
okay once you've done that then you can
just run the shiny apps deploy app and
then give it that app the directory that
contains your application so one of the
really nice things about it is that the
the server will use the same version of
our and installed all all the same
versions of the packages that you have
so that can simplify deployment a lot if
you've used a shiny server and you've
deployed apps there sometimes and you
may have run into problems where
packages are slightly bit they have been
different versions on your development
machine versus production and and
there's some incompatibilities in the
code that can happen that way so I'll
demonstrate this using a simple app okay
this is a really basic dashboard and
let's see any apps deploy up see what
your do is this in simple dashboard
oops I have multiple
so after specify my user name yep
so it'll do this stuff it it's deploying
it to shiny app so this usually takes
about a minute and when it's done it
should pop up a web browser just playing
that app but I let this run in the
background while I show you another way
to do it which is deploying to shiny
apps I owe using the publish button and
this might require I'm not sure this
might require one of the latest
development versions of our studio these
daily preview builds but those are worth
trying out anyway okay so this the
dashboard finished deploying and it just
popped up in my web browser and you can
see this URL winston Conneaut io /
simple dashboard and that's how it works
for the publish button well if I run the
application I can click on the
publish button here and this will
publish it there just in the same way
but I won't probably doing that now
since we already we've already deployed
it okay that okay so because we've
gotten to the end here so if you're some
other useful resources for learning
about this stuff there's a lot there's a
lot of stuff here but um you can see the
dashboard demo at this URL
Winston Johnny on Io slash activity -
Tech activity dashboard so let's go to
that page so if you want to see what my
friend Jared is doing right now you can
go visit this URL and again this is this
is real-time data so so it is actually
what he's doing right now if you wanna
learn more about shinee we have a whole
shiny site at our studio comm the shiny
dashboard documentation I mentioned
those links a couple of times before
leaflet shiny server shining up CIO and
admin lcae if you want to learn more
about the nuts and bolts about laying up
shiny dashboard and just about covers it
thanks Winston so let's take a couple of
questions we've been trying to answer
them along the way but they're putting
in fast and furious
then we can we can handle but there's
sort of a couple of themes might be
worth just talking about there lots of
questions about being able to use
different kinds of visualizations or or
third-party packages and I think the
general answer is you know it's anything
that that is it can be used with are can
be can be used in the dashboard but you
might want to comment a little further
on on that some of the popular
additional kinds of visualizations
people might use in a dashboard yeah so
any of the plug-in as you said any of
the plots that can be used in R can be
used in
in shiny and the dashboards so but you
know I mentioned ggplot2
a lot any of the base graphics base our
graphics plots can be it will just show
up in shiny if you if you use them you
can use lattice graphics and if you need
all your forms of map output there's
there's various mapping packages that
will that will display maps for you so
and yeah so there's many options
anything that are can use shiny can use
and the shine you can also use various
JavaScript libraries so we have another
another package called digraphs which is
for plotting time series now this is
done in the browser so it's it's like
it's a little bit more interactive and
we're working on building more of those
okay great and another question that
came up quite frequently any
recommendations for dynamic resizable
widgets you know your text boxes that
don't that instead of wrapping might
expand as the as they fill them in I
know it's a bit of a detail but do you
have any recommendation there um you
know I I think I'll have to look at that
question after this is done I need to
look at the details of of that like
exactly the specific use case okay and
you might just take a quick look at the
questions there as I said they're coming
in quite rapidly here but a number of
questions about deployment okay maybe
pull a couple of interesting ones here
questions and I can take one while you
keep why you look so there's a question
about the shinies server and it's in its
limitation the open source shiny server
to one hour process at a time that that
doesn't mean that only one person or one
app can be deployed you can play as many
apps or and have as many people use that
as they me as you need but it does mean
that it
that people are the application handles
user C really so depending on how long
it takes to go and do the activity that
the user has has instructed the shiny
app to do will would potentially delay
the next person right because everybody
has stacked up whereas with shiny server
pro and a certain of certain of the
commercial paid features of shiny apps
do you'll you'll find that you can
deploy multiple instances of our and and
eliminate that that degradation
potential yeah alright go ahead if
you've got a question there too you want
to pull out Winston
let's see yeah so someone's asking is
deployment on AWS through our studio
free so you know if you don't if you
deploy shiny server or shiny well if you
deploy shiny server on your own aw its
AWS instance that's free but if you if
you want to deploy to shiny apps on IO
which happens to be hosted on AWS
actually we do have a free tier don't
worry Roger
you know why I'm shiny apps yes yep on
China have said I oh there's a free tier
there's a way we put in our studio
branding bar on it and there's there's
certain resource limitations on it but
it should be fine for low usage apps
yeah somebody else asked which version
of ggplot supports brushing well this is
actually a feature the current version
I'm using the current version of ggplot
but I'm using a special version of shiny
it's on a development branch and I'm
gonna post the code for before that app
that demonstration app that I had I'm
gonna post that to our github webinars
site later today I need I just need to
make sure that you know the API keys are
cleaned up and there's no private too
much too private data that's being
revealed by it so that but that will
happen later today hey Winston this is a
question we get from a few people both
in webinars like
this in other places but the the four
dashboards that are representing a lot
of data do you know any any advice on
you know how how to to handle large data
sets yeah I mean if they're really large
you know no matter what you use via R or
something else it might take time to to
crunch that data and to massage it and
summarize it in a way that can be
displayed effectively so if that's the
case then you might need to schedule a
job to you know run that data crunching
every hour or daily and and then you can
save that output and then from one of
these dashboarding applications just
reading that that pre pre processed data
so I hope that's that's what's meant by
that question yeah I think that's a
reasonable suggestion no pre process as
much as possible I think is a generally
good advice when you have large data
sets for dashboards
okay so we'll try to get to more of
these shiny apps questions there's lots
of good and and by the way if you don't
know you can go to our Studios home site
our studio calm and just select products
and shiny apps and you'll find more
information about shiny apps
capabilities including authentication
and multiple instances and and and the
other features available to you if you
want to use our hosted service I see a
question here about interface to
Microsoft Excel there's there's ways to
read Excel read and write Excel files
but I don't I don't know well no there
may be a way to connect to a live Excel
session but I don't know much about that
but if you need to read and write files
that's that's something that can be done
okay we got a recent one here is it
possible to load new data in real time
and update the visualization I think yes
yeah yeah I'll just run that up again
and let's see this one
so if you're tracking Jared right now
there's a button here which does refresh
location data and what this does is this
just tells it to to contact that Web API
oops sorry
this just tells it to clicking on this
refresh location data button tells it to
hit that Web API again and it fetches
the data and read does the map so you
might not see much of a change in this
location actually if we click on it
right now but yeah he's probably not
moving anywhere but yeah this will
refresh right you can also set up timers
in SHINee using a function called
invalidate later or reactive timer that
will just tell it to re-execute or
refresh data every you know every minute
or five minutes or whatever specified
time you want that's another possibility
okay thanks so if you'd like to learn
more about shinee go to shinee doubt our
studio comm that's the best place to
learn it there's some great tutorials
there lots of examples both from us and
from users and and so let me conclude
today's webinar with just the request
that if you do have any interest in our
commercial products that's how we pay
for all this good stuff we'd love for
you to evaluate whether the features of
our commercial products our studio
server pro or shinee server pro are
right for your organization you can the
websites are here we'd love for you to
join us next at our next webinar where
we're actually going to spend more time
on the differences between our
open-source products and our commercial
products and the results of our survey
earlier for those of you who are curious
we had about 10 percent participation so
hopefully next time around we'll just
get more of you to participate but we
see that SHINee is actually used by a
good number of you already accel number
to a commercial bi tool and then custom
web development
rounding out the the most popular
answers and with that I think you know
how to stay in touch with us but if you
don't here are good ways we'd love to
see on Facebook LinkedIn communities
tweet at us and definitely stay on top
of our blog we're always
putting our new product announcements on
our blog so that's that's where you find
the latest information from us